researchers in Australia have created
flexible material with nanoscale glass
structures that can manipulate light a
potential precursor to smart contact
lenses that display information and
retro sense therapeutics will inject
viruses loaded with the DNA of
light-sensitive algae into the eye of a
legally blind person in the hopes of
restoring their sight in black and white
they saw coming here this is mine
this may be the most human-like robot
hand ever made researchers from the
University of Washington created the
anthropomorphic robot hand by laser
scanning the bones of a human hand and
3d printing artificial replicas and
finally connecting them with artificial
finger joints it's controlled by ten
servos that act as muscles with cable
that replicates the carpal tunnel and
hope is that someday this system could
be used as a scaffold for the growth of
grafted cells to regenerate human hands
tiny quartz discs could store data for
billions of years
first detailed in 2011 it stores data
via laser etched nano structures which
can be read by passing light through the
crystal and having an automated
microscope algorithm translate the light
changes the UK researchers now have a
working prototype and the next step is
to speed up the right time as well as
the read time of the discs that can
store 360 terabytes and withstand
temperatures up to 1,000 degrees and
have a room-temperature lifespan of 13.8
billion years to free up traffic
Switzerland is considering a special
tunnel for automated delivery trucks a
three lane tunnel located 50 meters
underground where allowed passage for
the electric delivery vehicles
the idea is to completely eliminate big
trucks in urban areas and replace them
with much smaller trucks that do the
basic point A to point B delivery but
first some private financing needs to
put the three point four billion dollar
bill and if that does happen the
earliest it would open is twenty thirty
here's an artist's rendering of the
first successfully analyzed atmosphere
of a super-earth a super-earth is a
plant outside of our solar system with a
mass higher than Earth's but much lower
than gas giants like Neptune
researchers from the University College
London recently analyzed 55 Cancri EES
atmosphere and discovered it consists
mainly of helium and hydrogen and do two
orbiting so close to its Sun it's at
least 2,000 degrees there tectonic
technologies is developing pressure
sensing mats for virtual reality they
use hundreds of small force plates with
measured data sent to a computer that
translates real-time reactions in the
game they've used it to simulate flying
bending shifting weight and stepping and
they hope to start selling these by the
end of 2016
scientists from the National Institute
of Polar Research revived Antarctic
tardigrades frozen for over 30 years
taken from frozen moss in 1983 and
stored at minus 20 degrees samples were
recently defrosted the Turner grades
essentially woke up from suspended
animation
ate some algae and went on to
successfully reproduce so yeah in the
spirit of using robots to augment human
ability researchers at Georgia Tech
created a three arms drummer the smart
arm responds not only to gestures but
also the music adheres so for example if
the drummer moves to play the hi-hat is
smart arm just to play the ride cymbal
the drummer scenario is used as a proof
of concept because it's reliant upon
precise timed movements but this idea
could be eventually implemented on
doctors mechanics or technicians who
could use an extra hand the next steps
are to link the movements directly to
the users brain I featured a soft
wearable robotic glove in mind-blown 96
developed at Harvard but this new XO
glove from Seoul National University is
more compact and more comfortable the
flexible waterproof polymer soft robot
is tendon driven using actuators and
allows grasping of various objects for
people with hand disabilities finally
hydro more fizz a water shaping device
for display and interaction potential
applications include the water
purposefully avoiding your hands if the
temperature is too hot or showing you
different shapes to indicate the weather
or if the water is safe to drink
honestly I'm showing you this just
because I think it looks cool I'm gonna
leave you with a full-scale spaceship
drop test and as always thanks
watching new ways of living and new
thinking have laid the foundation for
most of what is good in life today with
the promise of more tomorrow
as distant families have become
neighbors and as people have constantly
widened their viewpoints while
multiplying the number of their contacts
more desires have developed to be
satisfied
you